en el vídeo anterior empezamos a hablar
sobre la tasa de crecimiento poblacional
y de cómo se relaciona con la tasa de
natalidad y de mortalidad en una
población y eso lo relacionamos con
algunas fórmulas que se podrían
encontrar en el formulario de un examen
ape de biología y que parecen muy
complicadas
ahora vamos a extender esa conversación
para discutir otras fórmulas que podrían
encontrar y vamos a demostrar que las
operaciones se pueden realizar
intuitivamente usando un poco de
notación matemática entonces como un
pequeño repaso aquí tenemos el ejemplo
que ya habíamos visto que es una
población donde la tasa de natalidad era
de 60 conejitos al año aquí hablamos de
una población de conejitos y la tasa de
mortalidad era de 15 conejitos al año
cuál será la tasa de crecimiento
poblacional para este ejemplo bueno en
un año se espera que nazcan 60 conejitos
con lo que incrementarán la población
también se espera que morirán 15
conejitos lo que le resta a la población
así al final se obtiene un incremento
neto de 45 conejitos al año ahora para
poner eso en el lenguaje matemático del
formulario que encontrarán en un examen
ap de biología la notación que se
utiliza para la tasa de crecimiento
poblacional es una notación muy elegante
y la voy a escribir por acá les van a
poner que n es igual a la población n es
igual a la población y después para la
tasa de crecimiento poblacional se usa
una notación de cálculo que se expresa
como el cambio de la población entre el
cambio en el tiempo aquí estamos
hablando de algo que en cálculo se
conoce como cambio instantáneo pero por
ahora no tenemos que ser tan específicos
así que para la tasa de crecimiento
poblacional podemos usar esta anotación
y esto es igual a la tasa de natalidad
que en este caso es de 60 conejitos por
año
la notación que usan en el formulario
para la tasa de natalidad es simplemente
una b mayúscula aquí no usan la misma
anotación de acá si se podría pero esta
forma es más fácil de entender y bueno
después a eso se le resta la tasa de
mortalidad que se expresa con d
mayúscula esta es una de las fórmulas
que se podrán encontrar pero como pueden
ver también la pueden deducir
intuitivamente bien la siguiente idea
que me gustaría que analicemos es un
concepto conocido como tasa de
crecimiento poblacional per cápita
primero lo escribiré con palabras vamos
a pensar en el concepto de tasa
de crecimiento poblacional per cápita
bueno mire per cápita se refiere a un
promedio por persona o individuo y nos
dice cuál es aproximadamente la tasa de
crecimiento por individuo en este caso
cuál creen que sea pausa en el vídeo y
reflexionen un poco una forma de
definirla es como la tasa de crecimiento
poblacional dividida entre la población
neta es decir entre el número total de
personas o individuos que hay entonces
es igual a la tasa de crecimiento
poblacional entre la población et ahora
supongamos que tenemos una población de
450 conejitos cuál será la tasa de
crecimiento poblacional per cápita pausa
en el vídeo y traten de resolver bueno
si tenemos una población netas de 450
conejitos la tasa de crecimiento
poblacional por el número de individuos
que en este caso son conejos es igual a
vamos a ver ya sabíamos que la tasa de
crecimiento poblacional es de 45
conejitos por año y eso será por cada
450 conejitos entonces 45 entre 450 es
igual a 0.1 y para las unidades
conejitos se cancela y nos queda 0.1 por
año
pero porque la tasa de crecimiento
poblacional per cápita es tan
interesante bueno en la mayoría de las
poblaciones necesitamos al menos un
macho y una hembra para que se puedan
reproducir pero hay algunos organismos
que se pueden partir en dos y reproducir
a sexualmente de cualquier manera esto
nos da una idea aproximada de qué tanto
crece una población por año por
individuo ahora en el formulario de un
examen ap de biología la notación
matemática que se podrán encontrar se ve
así la tasa de crecimiento poblacional
per cápita generalmente se representa
con la letra r minúscula y esto es igual
a la tasa de crecimiento poblacional que
ya vimos que es la relación de cambio de
la población con respecto al tiempo de n
dt entre la población et
y ahora vamos a manipular esto un poco
algebraica mente para obtener otra
expresión multipliquemos ambos lados de
la ecuación por n mayúscula es decir por
la población neta y nos queda que de n
dt es igual a n por r&r por n vamos a
escribirlo en limpio nos queda que de n
dt es igual a la tasa de crecimiento
poblacional per cápita por la población
et
y nuevamente esto tiene mucho sentido
porque miren si este es el número de
individuos que hay actualmente y en un
año incrementa en promedio esta cantidad
entonces al multiplicar estas dos cosas
podemos conocer que tanto creció la
población en ese año pero si por alguna
razón no conociéramos estos números
vamos a verlo de otra manera
supongamos que tenemos una población de
1.000 conejitos entonces ahora n es
igual a 1000 conejitos y supongamos que
tenemos el mismo tipo de conejitos con
la misma probabilidad de reproducción
por lo tanto ya sabemos que r es igual a
0.1 por año entonces ahora para esta
población de conejitos cuál será la tasa
de crecimiento poblacional pausa en el
vídeo y traten de descubrir
bueno podemos decir que n de t es igual
a la tasa de crecimiento poblacional per
cápita que en este caso es 0.1 por año
por la población neta es decir por 1000
conejitos así que mil por una décima es
igual a 100 esto es igual a 100
conejitos por año espero que con esto
les quede un poco más claro por qué son
tan útiles este tipo de fórmulas que en
realidad son relativamente sencillas
observen que aunque esta es una
anotación de cálculo muy extravagante
simplemente nos dice que la tasa de
cambio de nuestra población es igual a r
por la población y en realidad esta es
una ecuación diferencial porque si
pensamos en cómo describe la población
esto nos está diciendo que es una
población que crece exponencialmente y a
eso se le conoce como ecuación de
crecimiento de exponencial lo escribiré
crecimiento
y exponencial
en sus clases de matemáticas y de
cálculo o incluso en pre cálculo
estudiarán el crecimiento exponencial
pero en una clase de biología solamente
necesitamos pensar en cómo aplicar la
ecuación pero si se preguntan qué es el
crecimiento exponencial imagínense que
tienen una población de conejos aquí
tenemos el tiempo y este eje representa
a la población al principio tenemos una
cierta población aquí pero que después
crecerá exponencialmente y entre más
grande sea la erre la curva de
crecimiento exponencial será más
empinada ahora esto describe qué tanto
pueden crecer las poblaciones si no son
limitadas por el medio ambiente es decir
si tienen suficiente terreno agua y
comida como necesiten si esto fuera
cierto en algún momento los conejos
podrían ocupar toda la superficie de la
tierra y del universo pero obviamente
sabemos que eso no es realista porque
cualquier ecosistema tiene una
capacidad de carga natural es decir hay
una cantidad limitada de comida y de
terreno y en realidad habría tantos
conejos que sería más fácil para los
depredadores que se los pudieran comer
pero eso lo platicaremos en el siguiente
vídeo cómo podríamos adaptar la ecuación
de crecimiento exponencial a una
situación real si en algún momento la
población estuviera alcanzando la
capacidad de carga natural del medio
ambiente